il faut trouver quelque chose pour le
stage dans le mé que je vois il y a un
technicien pour ordinateur en gros
développeur mobile je sais pas ex ce que
c'est mais je suis pas sûr qu'il y a des
m d'informati qui prennent des
stages venue l'idée de faire pour moi un
métier dans l'informatique alors ça
c'est quand tu as un bulletin qui
t'ouvre toutes les portes et ben du coup
tu t'ouvres les portes un peu
pour aller là où tu as envie d'aller
d'accord à
CH il niau de ou jeand si jeis pas rus
histoire géographie géopolitique et
Scien
[Musique]
poli
l
pouriner culture AC
as tion à tous c lauréa un femme de
manga manga BD et ben bravo on est fier
de vous he
bravo je montre pas ce que je ressens
parce que les autres pourraient me
juger j'ai appris à garder ma
personnalité à moi pour moi et à montrer
ce que je voulais montrer aux autres
j'aimerais être complètement visible je
m'en vais en Angleterre P un an
tout
lesis tes amis vont te manquer ou pas
ils vont me manquer mais c'est pas grave
c'est sûr je vais me sentir seul à
moment d'abord je sais toi d'abord en
roue Coline par ou à
Manchester des fois elle se moque de moi
c'est des moqu so sur le physique ou
soit sur mon St vestimentaire ou et
cetera d'accord rigole genre en me
regardant mal et
[Musique]
cetera cette année ça a été très
compliqué l'année prochaine je vais
changer de collège je quitte les
gailloles et je vais dans le collège
privé juste derrière j'espère que c'est
pour le mieux mais bon
voilà Lilou Rywan Mael Colin Mohamed ils
sont nés en 2008 leurs chemins se sont
croisés en classe de 6e à
Rennes depuis nous les suivons dans leur
vie sur une décennie avec des questions
comment grandit-on dans les années
2020 quels seront leurs parcours qui
seront-ils demain les réponses se
dessinent avec le temps à travers cette
série documentairire qu'il est
impossible d'écrire à
l'avance voici quelques moments de vie
capturés dans l'année celle de leur 14
[Musique]
ans
j'aurais pu faire genre je mange une
salade de fruits ou un truc comme
[Musique]
ça c'est un peu difficile niveau santé
mentale je continue à grandir j'ai
encore beaucoup de de questions
existentielles sur moi-même j'ai
toujours des crises
d'angoisse c'est un peu difficile il y a
des bons moments il y a des mauvais
moments mais c'est moins sombre je
remonte la pente jeis te dire d'aller te
préparer parce qu'il était quand même un
petit peu ça
[Musique]
va
je me maquille parce que genre ça me
[Musique]
détend je maquillage qui va avec mes
vêtements bah là j'ai un P bleu jeis un
maquillage bleu
[Musique]
quoi moi ça m'a l'air
bieni il va
m'attendreci
bonne journée bis bonne
journée les gailloles ça a vraiment été
un endroit où où je venais la boule au
ventre o je m'enfer aux toilettes pour
avoir aucune interaction avec
personne quand tu te fais arceler en
plus en 4è c'est la période un peu tu te
construis où tu as grandi et cetera en
plus tuas un mal-être présent bah c'est
très
difficile sur ce plan là je me sens
mieux je pense que la classe à
L'Assomption c'est la meilleure classe
que j'ai eu depuis le
collège j'avais hyper peur en tout début
d'année d'avoir une mauvaise classe et
cetera je m'imaginais le pire je imagine
c'est encore pire qu'avant mais moi j'ai
une classe vraiment bien je les aime
tous bonjour bonjour j'ai deux meilleurs
amis en ce moment
mais ouias fait le truc sur bless Pascal
c'est sur pour vendredi il faut faire un
traitement de
texte je vais faire ça aujourd'hui et ça
prend beaucoup de temps ça prend pas
beaucoup temps il sont un peu comme moi
genre ce sont pas des gens
populaires mais c'est pas des gens non
plus au fond du fond quoi on a un peu le
même statut social
quoi alors c'est la deuxième crise de la
guerre froide qu'on va examiner
aujourd'hui l' j'ai note beaucoup plus
dur que Gol il y a beaucoup plus de
contrôle j'ai pu remarquer il prépare un
niveau très très très élevé et le le mur
il va durer jusqu'à sa chute en 1989 le
6 octobre 1989 gorbachchev arrive à
Berlin est donc c'est la réunification
de de l'Allemagne si de droite il y a
beaucoup plus de discipline
parallèle on peut beaucoup plus
facilement avoir des es de
col des sanctions de droites squant
alors elle détermine de triangles dont
les longueurs des côtés sont
proportionnales par exemple s'il y a une
baston à L'Assomption les deux ont des
heures de col pendant des semaines il
des rendez-vous avec leurs parents alors
que au G il voit juste la CPE après ils
ont rien et après il recommen
après
[Musique]
ent des gens c'est
des ce genre de personne c'est c'est
répugant ah oui oh là là mon Dieu monu
au Gaul les garçons sont maintenant les
doyens du collège ils abordent les
sujets d'actualité avec plus de
[Musique]
maturité donc terme générique dessin de
presse
[Musique]
à l'intérieur du dessin de presse la
caricature c'était Mavis quels sont les
thèmes abordés dans le dessin de presse
en
général la politique
ouis l'actualité oui encore l'économie
oui vous avez compris le
principe bien la consignée la suivante
chacun va trouver une illustration sur
la thématique suivante vous m'illustrer
un préjugé
sur les jeunes on va séclater des
préjugés sur la jeunesse il y en a à
tous les coins de rue je ne veis pas un
dessin commun à de
élèvesz vousz encore de 3
[Musique]
minutes bien
stop il est
sale sa chambre est une porcherie les
mouches me disent que c'est une odeur à
tomber par terre il est scotché à son
écran c'est bien c'est
réussi je vous
confie une petite caméra thermique vous
allez au niveau du hall de
le du
bâtiment les gars les gars je vous
propose qu'on fasse une photo vue
d'ensemble des deux portes du
hall il travaille même sur les
préoccupations très concrètes du
moment mitraille là nous on voit on voit
juste là la chaleur elle est en train de
s'échapper donc
ok là
voilà c'est bon on a tout ce qu'il
faut alors on va faire petit
retour rapide alors est-ce que vous
pouvez les gars nous expliquer ce qu'on
voit là on peut voir que le froid
rentre dans le bâtiment à travers cette
porte si on fait ça chez vous
maintenanten en pire ça laisse vraiment
tout passer ça laisse tout passer ouais
vous le sentez à l'intérieur oui rwan
non c'est pas flagrant flagrant
l'appartement il est vieux donc je pense
que auss quand même un peu et dans le
contexte actuel ça veut dire quoi aussi
si vous suivez un petit peu les
actualités en ce moment c'est
problématique c'est problématique
pourquoi le prix de l'énergie coûte de
plus en plus cher donc c'est de
l'énergie perdue souhaite une bonne
journée à 600 km au nord de la salle de
techno se trouve la ville anglaise de
[Musique]
cette année Coline est donc
mancunienne à 14 ans 600 km loin de ses
amis ça change la
vie à Rennes des fois quand je me
baladais dans la rue j'entendais genre
des bribes de discussion entre certaines
personnes alors que là la plupart du
temps quand je sors dans la rue je suis
toute
seule collège c'est pas simple on est
moins de 100 filles pour plus de 200
garçons tout le monde est dispersé dans
les cours et c'est encore plus difficile
de créer des liens parce que il y a pas
un groupe classe c'est pas des gens avec
qui je me dis tiens j'ai envie de rester
ami avec toute ma
vie Coline au collège il faudra se
l'imaginer la caméra n'a pas eu le droit
de dépasser les grillages et les slogans
[Musique]
bienveillants la maison de cololline est
plus
[Musique]
accueillante embarqué par les parents
dans une année de césure Coline est
arrivée il y a 3
mois
til oh mon dieu mon t-shirt pas tout à
fait
convaincu j'ai trop de devoir en
mat qu'est-ce que tu t'es dit en
arrivant tu t'es fait wou 1 any
euh je me suis dit oh ça va être
long et
voilà et là tu te dis quoi
oh il reste encore 6 mois
[Musique]
B quque chose comme ça je crois c'est
une
expression la compréhension ça fait
bizarre je comprends pas tout je P c'est
encore la barrière de la
langue
bah l'expression orale ça bloque j'ai eu
du mal àer en fait j'ai peur de faire
des phrases qui ressemblent à rien qui
veulent rien dire donc je ne dis rien tu
passes des journées entières parler à
personne
[Musique]
ouais la semaine s bien
passé c'est chiant l' c'est trop trop
chant que l'intégration est plus
difficile et plus lente que ce qu'on
s'était imaginé et qu'on est un peu plus
isolé que ce à quoi on
s'attendait bon mais du coup au collège
ça se passe bien quand même ça passe ça
passe c'est pas éclatant j'ai n pas
envie d'y aller le matin je me lève je
me dis pas oh c'est bon je vais y aller
ça va êre trop bien je me dis oh
c'est chiant j'ai envie de rester de
fond de mon lit c'est bon ça te paraî
com là ça me paraît bien hop on mange
c'est contacts amico pour le moment ils
sont en
France et c'est pour ça que c'est ussi
pour ça que c'est difficile je pense
alors j'avance là dedans donc là c'est
ça c'est ton cours c'est des trucs que
tu
as oui ça c'est tout depuis le début je
réponds
juste c'est bon c'est bon c'est
bon ça tu l'as lu ou pas euh et par
contre si je veux bien t'aider mais tu
laisses ton téléphone merci est-ce que
tu as un endroit là où ça parle des
modes d'action des globule blanc euh
c'est là je à mon avis c'est dans c'est
jamais facile de ne pouvoir échanger que
par sms ou que par téléphone de pas être
présent de savoir ce qui se passe des
choses dans le groupe alors qu' elle est
pas làfin c'est pas simple on en est
conscient mais là malheureusement on
peut pas faire
grandchose donc c'est les modes d'action
des globules blancs contre les
pathogènes et il en faut trois
ou il y a les là ça va être relou là
ouais je sais je je je je je dis que je
peux pas
h
euh donc il y a 3 mois que tu dis bon
ils vont pas manquer au pire ahors en
fait non non en fait non je pense il me
manque plus genre que que
j'imaginais maisah je passais quand même
la moitié de ma journée avec eux genre
de 8h à 17h j'étais avec eux au collège
12 13
14 ouais tu as mis un peu trop là ouais
j'en ai mis trop pour Timothé othé
j'allais avec lui tous les jours au
collège on tous les jours ensemble non
Mo je veux plein de boug tu les vois
quasiment autant que ta famille quoi
genre ça ma
famille je pense que tout le monde a
besoin de de gens avec qui je sais pas
partager des
trucs
parler faire des conneries des trucs
comme ça
quoi
encore
uneée et ça tu l'as pas
ici
non tout simplement parce que je n'ai
pas d'amis au collège c'est pas facile 2
3 donc il te manque beaucoup
là
voilà bonjour à tous aujourd'hui c'est
une séance effectivement sur la vi
classe d'habitude et puis là je viis
vous préparer à vos 3 jours de stage
parce qu' a Timothé qui m'écoute pas he
Timothé tu es d'accord avec moi
donc le but est quand même de vous
montrer que vous êtes capable de montrer
une bonne image ce que je vais faire
c'est je vais vous donner cette feuill
là vous allez en fait du coup répondre
aux questions d'accord
alors un peu en avance oui oui mais pas
trop est-ce que je dois être pctuel bah
bien sûr que tu dois être ponctuel c'est
quoi cette
question j'ai j'is pas besoin d'
question comme ça que dois-je faire euh
appeler ouais appeler
l'entreprise dois-je faire attention à
mon vocabulaire pendant toute la durée
du stage même en pause bien sûr
maintenant vous devez vous préparer vous
présenter donc il y a quelqu'un qui fait
le tuteur ou le le chef d'entreprise et
l' personne qui fait j'arrive je me
présente c'est la première impression
qu'on a la première rencontre avec son
tuteur sa tutrice voilà moi je trouve
que ça c'est important bon merci
entr
[Musique]
entre
allezigoler dis
[Applaudissements]
tu complex je sais c'est
complexe
monur de 3è oui donc vous allez être
avec moi pendant les deux jours suivants
je m'appelle Bruno Alvarez chef de
rédaction pour le
journal alors est-ce que tu sais est-ce
que tu sais ce que tu vas faire ici
pendant les de jours un stage
d'observation je va observer la vie de
du journal pendant 2 jours est-ce que tu
sais pourquoi tu as choisi West France
tout d'abord parce que c'est le
principal journal de la région et puis
même si je ne suis pas sûr de faire
journaliste comme métier c'est une des
voix qui m'intéresse très bien on va
pouvoir
commencer là c'est mieux pouris France
bah parce que c'est le principal truc de
région enfin montre que je connais un
peu Ouest France tu lis wouest France
bien sûr ouais bah monre tu dis je l
wouest France ça m'intéresse j'aime
suivre l'actualité ca tu montres que tu
es un peu tu es pas passionné de
journalisme non plus mais tu vois tu
montres que tu t'y connais un peu que tu
suis l'actualité que tu vois que ça
t'intéresse de faire
ça matin ma file peut-être vers sa
future
vie
stressé non ça va ça super très
intéressant c'est sa première journée
mtro boulot
dodo faut pas que ce soit non plus la
seule chose importante dans la vie le
boulot
mais faut que ce soit une passion si tu
travailles juste pour gagner de l'argent
ça n aucun
intérêt stationger tu prends pas de
plaisir aller au travail tu te lèves le
matin tu vas au travail tu rentres le
soir tu manges tu dors tu retoures au
travail mais tu t'amuses pas tu es pas
content de ce que tu fais ça
[Musique]
intérêt
bonjour
bonjour bienvenue je suis BR je suis le
chef de la rédaction ici bien voilà ça
c'est le plateau de la
rédaction donc voilà écoute bienvenue tu
vas pouvoir t'installer je vais te
donner un journal je ne sais pas si tu
l'as tu as pu le lire ce matin déjà Mo
j'ai juste
plus
le la première page et le début de
monde France d'accord bon on accueille
aujourd'hui ma qui est en 3e donc en
stage journaliste parmi les journalistes
ma apprend les bases du
métierour d'abord l'observation ville
décide de passer le centrreeville en
zone à trafic limité et autr on a une
affaire en cours qui est intéressante à
la
surpartement c'est un coup de filet
c'est 6 mois d'enquête les nouveau modes
de livraison de la DR voir la maison
[Musique]
demain onance tout ok ça marche on en
reste là tu vois la suite de la réunion
à laquelle tu as assisté ce matin quand
on a fait la conférence de rédaction
l'ensemble de l'équipe ensuite j'ai cet
outil là de pagination c'est le
paginateur en fait et là en dessous et
ben je peux crire mon texte puis
l'interview et vous vous avez commencé
par être simplement journaliste j'ai
fait la fac puis
euh les deux écoles de journalisme
d'accord j'ai fait des stages là de
pratique et puis après tu fais des piges
et cetera tu fais tes premières ares
jusqu'à ce que je suis emboché par le
journal d'accord j'ai d'abord été prof
de philo ah vous donc vous avez pas fait
d'école particulière après pas fait ce
qu'on appelle les grandes écoles de
journal et ah monour ben moi dès le
lycée je voulais être journaliste je
voulais être chroniqueuse musicale au
début ah
oui quelques prises de notes pour le
rapport de
stage essaie de prendre le coup un petit
peu ce qu'on dit tu vois pour et
évidemment le terrain c'est où la
conférence de presse à l'arbore au
cinéma Arbor d'accord et la curiosité
qui va avec et vous avez fait une école
particulière après le lycé non j'ai fait
l'université en fait j'ai fait
communication j'ai fait de la
linguistique aussi
[Musique]
d'accord
et il dure combien de temps festival ça
c'est une semaine en
génér ravi d'accueillir encore ce
festival pour sa 34e édition merci à
vous et bon
festival en fait dans le journal La Une
c'est pas toujours le même journaliste
qui a fait ah non ça dépend de la
qualité
d'accord alors je vais expliquer un
petit peu donc moi mon travail donc pour
l'article que j'ai ici il m'arrive de
manière brute en fait je peux refaire
des modifications dedans d'accord alors
av vient il retape un bus d'un autre âge
pour sauvegarder la mémoire du tu vois
tout de suite qu' a un petit souci le
titre il est trop long comme moi j'ai
pas beaucoup d'espace pour le dire je
vais gagner de la place comme ça et tu
imaginais que c'était comme ça ou pas
faire un journal ah non on aime pas non
tu veux être journaliste ou ben oui
c'est une des voix qui m'intéresse c'est
vraiment un plus si tu peux déjà a des
journaux sou dans les lycées qui sont
écrits par les lcé en fait et après si
vraiment tu continues là-dedans quand tu
postules en fait dans des écoles pour
devenir journaliste il regardent
beaucoup en fait si tu as déjà un petit
peu d'expérience d'accord merci
beaucoupen la fin de l'hiver n'est plus
si loin le brevet des collèges non plus
l'Ural blanc allez instzv encore moins
je rappelle que demain
votre rapport de stage on va faire un
petit exercice de
relaxation de visualisation
d'anticipation pour essayer de mettre le
stress à distance alors vous êtes tous
assis posz main sur votre chaise vous
êtes enraciné par terre tranquillement
vous vous isolez de tout le reste sauf
de ma
voix vous allez fermer les yeux et là
vous allez tranquillement adopter une
respiration calme donc je vais vous
reconstituer le déroulement de votre
séance de demain vous vous voyez en
train de faire tout ce que je vous
dit ce
soir je prépare mes affairire matin de
l'épreuve vous vous levez à l'heure qui
vous permet de vous préparer sans vous
stresser vous arrivez au collège avec un
petit peu d'avance vous êtes en sécurité
dans ces lieux
tout va
bien
3 prier examen
ouais c'est
stressant
non je sais pas c'est ça le pire c'est
uation comme une autre en fait c'est ça
le truc qu' faut se dire mais c'est
stressant encore plus je sais pas
[Musique]
pourquoi vous allez arriver dans la
salle qui correspond à ce qui est
inscrit sur votre convocation vous vous
y
présenteer vous êtes en confiance vous
respirez si jamais vous sentez encore un
petit peu
stressé vous restez à l'extérieur vous
attendez que le jury vous Perm
tu as fait tes exercices de respiration
non ça va franchement je stress
pas je pense que ça sera
bon le jury vous invite à rentrer dans
la
salle bon ben les garçons c'est à nous
allez Ran et après ce sera Mohamed vous
vous installez vous êtes là vous êtes en
sécurité vous avez tout ce qui vous tu
as une clé oui et ben vas-y tu
t'installes et là vous êtes en train de
vous visualiser face au jury ce jury est
bienveillant ce jury vous regarde mais
il ne peut pas vous regardez tout le
temps parce qu'il doit prendre des notes
n'oubliez pas que vous êtes chronométrie
5 minutes noral et vous vous
lancez quand tu démares on
démarre bonjourj hi je vais vous
présenter mon stage chez pantasonic qui
est une
ESN c'est
une entreprise de service numérique
bonjour à tous je m'appelle Mohamed et
je vais vous présenter mon oral sur
l'entreprise Atem donc Atem est une
entreprise basée dans le traitement de
vidéo pour des clients tels que TF1 la
BBC orange et cetera d'accord donc nous
sommes allés au au Seddas de gufin pour
changer un ordinateur qui ventiler trop
le produit Titan va tout simplement
encoder et compacter un maximum la vidéo
pour entièrement la faire passer dans un
flux de 24 bit secondes le 3è jour
j'ai avec l'aide du technicien changer
un écran sur un PC portable car la dalle
était fissurée lors de de mon stage on a
pu rencontrer le poste de Pio donc produ
hers qui est tout simplement le
représentant d'un produit j'ai bien aimé
mes 3 jours de stage c'était assez
instructif et ils ont été très gentil du
coup je tenais à remercier l'entreprise
de m'avoir chaleureusement accueilli et
merci beaucoup j'ai terminé d'accord ok
des questions du coup par rapport à ton
projet personnel du coup ça s'inscrit
bien dans le dans euh bah ça m'a quand
même bien ouvert les voix parce que
c'est vrai que au début j'étais assez
réticent après c'est vrai que moi je
pense que dans ma tête il y a trop de
choses que je veux faire en fait je
voudrais me spécialiser dans l'anglais
aussi bah dans les matières telles que
laasvt peutêtre une spécialisation dans
la médecine tu voudrais allier tout ça
c'est c'est très compliqué mais non
c'est pas du tout compliqué à réaliser
tout ce que tu viens de dire est
totalement réalisable et on t encourage
d'ailleurs d'accord merci beaucoup
ok
bien merci
moi franchement je voudrais un travail
qui me
plaise puis voilà après je fais d'autres
choses derrière en face de ton nom tu
signes faut bien gagner sa vie pour
pouvoir payer de quoi se loger se
nourrir vas-y d'un côté c'est un travail
donc je me dis ça doit quand même avoir
une certaine place dans la vie mais
est-ce que pour autant ça devrait me
drainer toute mon énergie j'espère pas
en fait ça serait d'avoir les deux en
même temps avoir une une famille des
enfants avec une situation aisée et euh
et un boulot qui dans lequel je suis
épanoui et où je me
plais voilà merci les garçons bonne
journée d' merci à
vous
[Musique]
moi en fait j'ai envie d'avoir un
travail où je me sens bien où je où je
sais où pas forcément je me lève le
matin yes une très bonne journée dans
mon travail bah non parce que bah le
travail c'est pas tous les jours comme
ça non mais c'est c'est pas tous les
jours comme ça en métier ou où je survis
quoi je me ferai jamais de sacrifice je
ferai jamais de j'empilerai pas les
cadavres pour avoir les métiers de MVE
quoi enfin c'est pas non mais c'est
clair mais tu penses que le stage que tu
as fait là par que tu as vu t ressources
humaines ça t'a un peu motivé pour
travailler ou ou c'est encore trop lo
travailler en cours ouais enfin oui
réussir en cours en tout cas après c'est
dur tous les jours ça je sais bien mais
moi oui ça m'a motivé pour pour faire
pour faire pour faire un bac techno STMG
Scien technologi du management et de la
gestion des fois céit un peu cette porte
qui m'intéressait moi je pense que oui
ça ça peut te correspondre et en plus
par rapport à ce que tu veux tu aimerais
faire plus tard alors tu par tu parlais
plus de de de marketing de communication
publicité tu apprends ça il y a quand
même des cours spécifiques et aussi pour
faire de la gestion en entreprise ou des
ressources humaines voilà c'est pas
complètement c'est pas complètement
anodin quoi donc c'est bien quo se
renseigner sur ça ouais ça peut être
intéressant ouis et par contre du coup
il va falloir qu'on qu'on réfléchisse
aussi
sur bah sur les lycées qui qui proposent
cette cette filière technologique
ouais et du coup
cou il y en a beaucoup rikini Jean d'
Jean massé je le curry lycée René
Descartes pourquoi tu veux pas aller à
Château parce que en fait si si tu veux
aller à Château c'est pour faire une
bonne générale quoi avoir un niveau
hyper bon si tu veux faire
du que du général moi tu vois si je vais
à château et que je fais enfin moi je ve
pas faire déjà je vaux pas faire de
général parce que pour moi j'ai envie de
m'orienter direct quoi parce que moi
j'ai pas j'ai envie de faire quelque
chose de concvie de sentir un métier
sentir un métier voilà c'est ça
exactement je pr franchement château
brillant ça a quand même une une
réputation d'être hyper exigeant quoi et
c'est vrai qu' à l'entrée en seconde il
pousseent quand même à les élèves après
c'est bien à se dépasser il mettent
quand même pas mal la pression moi j'ai
extrêmement du mal avec les cours même
faut pas que je faut pas que je craque
franchement si on si on me fait si on me
stresse comme ça je ma santé mentale
part en couille he ouais vraiment bah tu
as raison et en fait moi maintenant
maintenant psychologiquement en parlant
il faut que je fasse très attention
parce que bah gen enfin c'est c'est
c'est je dis ça honnêtement j'ai besoin
d'équilibre sinon je peux péter un câble
voilà moi je veux je je veux des je veux
des choses simples
quoi moi la pression j'ai envie de faire
de faire faire ça en mode chill tu vois
genre aller en cours travailler et puis
voilà rentrer chez soi
moi j'ai envie de profiter de de ma
jeunessete manière de pas penser au
travail que les notes n'est pas une
emprise sur moi je pense que la classe
àasstion c'est la meilleure classe que
j'ai eu collège il y a beaucoup plus de
respect je me suis plus sereine aller en
cours
déjà
pour j'ai beaucoup de traumatisme quand
j'étais au g par j'ai beaucoup de mal en
sport
le sport g je vivais comme si j'étais
inférieur en fait comme si j'étais un
animal quoi donc on a un groupe
Maximilien VI Thom et un groupe avec
Paul
louamilleélix c'est parti je savais pas
comment je pvais remédier quoi je disais
mais pourquoi je suis inférieur
je et c'est vrai que maintenant je sais
pas je rate un
truc je pas une personne qui fait oh
mais non tuabus et du coup genre je
prends hyper à cœur et j'arrive plus à
respirer la personne elle remarque tout
de suite et elle dit que qu'elle qu'elle
est désolé et voilà on va y arriver la
première fois que ça m'aré j'ai trouvé
ça hyper surprenant j' mode mais c'est
un rêve là enfin est-ce que ça existe
vraiment les personnes qui qui se
rendent compte du mal qu'elles font mais
si en fait
on tu vois quand m' allez c'est la Vonne
c'est la
vonnees
bien joué ça c'est bien ça voilà j'avis
tellement eu de de situations injustes
en me disant c'est moi le problème c'est
c'est moi qui est trop sensible c'est
moi qui prend tout mal alors que la
situation c'est clairement du
harcèlement c vraiment P très sombre
pour moi
vraiment moi si je je commeou comme ce
VI faire très propr j'ai des grosses
idées noires je men faire mets souvent
aux toilettes pour pleurer t les larmes
de mon corps
merci bien joué très bon match pour
vous gagé j'ai gagné deux fois dessus
avec Camille et avec bien en fait chaque
seconde je me disais est-ce que tu peux
survivre les 10 prochaines secondes et
du coup c'est comme ça que j'avançais
dans la journée mais mais tout ce que je
pensais c'était à rentrer chez moi je je
même rien que quand je partais en cours
quand j'étais sur le chemin dans le bus
ou sur le chemin de l'école j'étais en
mode alleer tu survis ça s'effarcera
jamais les mauvais souvenir et j'aurais
bien aimé avoir
avoir une
adolescence plus simple mais j'ai
survécu et je suis je suis contente
peêtre encore
[Musique]
là c'est toi Lilou bah oui c'est moi
d'accord jeis te retouver sur insta mais
j'avais j'avais oublié de m'abonner à
ton compte parce que j'étais pas sûr que
ce soit toi tu veux tu peux m'ajouter ça
me dérange pas ah oui d'accord est-ce
que tu pourras t'abonner au bien s'il te
plat ouis t'inquète t'inquiète ça va en
ce moment ouais ouais ça va ça t'inquiè
c'est plus facile de se faire des amis B
des réseaux sociaux quoi moi en plus
j'ai du mal à venir parler aux gens en
général donc tu vois c'est un peu un
raccourci un peu pour parler avec les
gens qu'on voit l'Assomption tous les
amis que j'ai maintenant j'ai réussi à
les avoir grâce au réseaux sociaux en
fait si les réseaux sociaux n'existaient
pas on aura une vie totalement
différente alors moi j'ai Instagram
Instagram Instagram j'ai snapchat
snapchat et TikTok j'en ai pas
et j'en aurai pas de siô donc une par je
sais pas si j'aurais le droit je sais
pas si j'en auraai envie non plus donc
toute façon pour l'instant j'ai pas de
téléphone
donc des fois je poste des stories de ce
que je fais ou c'est juste pour avoir un
aperçu un peu de ma vie en
général en ce moment un des sujets qui
m'intéresse c'est le airsoft ça c'est du
[Musique]
airsoft regarde des chaînes qui a
presque que sur Instagram qui font des
trucs duumisti
quoi je sa m pas quand ça
marche je
pas j'ai un ordi ça me
suffit je regarde l'image de
[Musique]
basket je suis pas vent beaucoup
d'influenceur je suis beaucoup de
chanteur je suis Pierce l PIP Selena
Gomez Taylor Swift orelson
l'OM après ils sont les chanteurs ils
sont tous un peu influenceurs justement
est-ce que les influenceurs
t'influencent j'ai envie de dire non ça
m'influence pas j'irais pas dire jusque
là parce que je réfléchis un minimum
avant de de me dire ce produit il est
bien et
[Musique]
tout pas parce que demain je vois un
influenceur qui veut vendre des baskets
que bah je vais les acheter influenceur
c'est vraiment les publicités
d'aujourd'hui parce que la personne tu
vois tu peux lui faire confiance entre
autres parce que tu vois ces vidéos
souvent si tu veux devenir beau gosse
c'est pas de la muscu qu'il faut que tu
fasses mais plutôt de la chirurgie
estétique taule une approche très pote à
pote quoi quand tu tu vois des
influenceurs tu dis mais ils ont
vraiment la vie parfaite ils partent en
après ils vont faire ils vont faire du
surf à Los Angeles non bah tuen sais
rien qu'ils ont la vie parfaite en fait
ils montrent juste qu'ils ont envie de
te montrer en
[Musique]
fait on voit beaucoup sur les réseaux
sociaux de gens qui ont qui ont un
physique incroyable qui sont musclés
beau qui on confiance en eux c'est beau
et donc tu te dis à toi-même il faut que
je ressemble à ça
[Musique]
je culpabilisais énormément
après en gros depuis plusieurs années
déjà je suis pas méga à l'aise avec mon
corps Jes
bien je voyais beaucoup de choses sur
les
réseaux de de gens qui parlait de
comment perdre du poids tout ça des
recettes saines des recettes des
recettes perte de poids ou des choses
comme ça ça donc j'ai vu énormément
d'informations et j'en ai ressorti une
chose de ce trop plein d'information
c'est que pour perdre du poids ou pour
perdre de la masse grasse il fallait
être en déficit calorique donc un pour
ne pas stimuler l'insuline réduisez le
sucre mais également les féculants de ne
mangez pas trop souvent n sommes pas des
vaches ne broutez pas toute la journée
même prolongez votre jaune nocturne de
12h à 13 14 15 16h pour moins stimuler
l'insuline dites-moi en commentaire si
ça vous a
aidé je me suis mise à faire hyper
attention à tout ce que je mangeais et
je me suis mise à éviter les calories au
maximum donc j'ai changé toute mon
alimentation comme j'essayais d'éviter
au maximum les calories quand je prenais
quelque chose je me suis mis à compter
tout ce que je mangeais on va au frais
il nous reste du C comment non pas
beaucoup tu peux en reprendre
[Musique]
je te laisse prendre les bananes ouais
j'ai essayé beaucoup de
recettes saine donc c'estàd on remplace
on remplace le sucre par la banane ou
des trucs sans beurre sans sucre tout ça
tout
[Musique]
ça je fais une salade
basiqueess de faire le calorique
[Musique]
possible au début je mettais des
féculants puis comme j'ai vu que les
féculants c'était quand même beaucoup
plus calorique que de la salade j'ai
changé le riz complet pour de la
salade ma mère l'avait déjà dit
plusieurs fois qu'il fallait que je
mette des féculants dans mes dans mes
salade le midi à aucun moment je l'ai
écouté parce que sur les réseaux
justement j'avais vu tellement
d'informations contradictoire que pour
moi le seul conseil valable aurait été
celui d'unun professionnel de santé
quelqu'un qui me dit tu mets ta santé en
danger si tu fais pas
ça c'est vrai qu'en matière d'infos
contradictoire
entre les réseaux sociaux et les appels
à la malbouffe dans les rues de
Manchester il y a de quoi se
perdre
là on peut y
aller gauche droite ou tout droit et
gauche
après exactement presque dans ce
bâtiment là à droite
[Musique]
ou ici en Angleterre il y a pas mal de
restaurants qui mettent les calories sur
le
menu donc ça ça m'aidait pas
mal donc du coup je prenais souvent le
le plat moin
tout le monde est content de son
choix des calories Coline en a quand
même brûlé pas mal à découvrir
[Musique]
l'Angleterre
VO alà le bilan de l'année donc céit
c'est une bonne expérience mais j'ai pas
aimé c'est une bonne expérience quand tu
as pas aimé c'est ça en quoi c'est une
bonne expérience bah j'ai appris plein
de
trucs j'ai quand même un niveau
d'anglais super cool puis même sans
parler juste de l'anglais tu vois les
maths ils ont un niveau supérieur les
science aussi donc du coup j'ai bah j'ai
un meilleur niveau en science et en
maths le volet c'est beaucoup
mieux je fais deux fois par semaine du
volet je préfère le volet ici qu'en
France enfin je me sens un peu plus en
confiance ici je trouve le groupe il est
mieux moi je me sens un peu plus
[Musique]
inclu j'ai appris que quand même les
Anglais et les français même si il y a
genre 500 km d'écart même pas ils sont
pas du tout pareil ils ont pas les mêmes
moyens de fonctionner que ce soit pour
la scolarité ou même en dehors de ça
dans la vie de tous les
jours moi je pensais que ça allait être
super cool et tout je pensais que
j'allais me faire des potes je pensais
que ça allait aller vite et tout et que
ça allait être gre vraiment une super
expérience au final je pense que je
m'attendais à beaucoup et du coup j'ai
été super
déçu par le fait de notamment power the
pot par le fait de ouais l'école aussi
parce que moi je pensais qu'ils allaient
faire aussi un peu plus attention enfin
je veux dire les proches ils font pas
forcément attention à toi
[Musique]
ouais oh tu es là ah
coucou ça va
ouais to non bah oui moi ça va bah j'ai
repris les cours aujourd'hui j'avais une
semaine de vacances en Écosse c'était
cool c'est bien et voilà j'aiis
aujourd'hui je me suis un peu fait chier
mais c'est pas grave ça change pas
beaucoup d'habitude
he toujours tout seu toujours pas d'amis
tout ça ah ou mais tu pas ditéta all
ouais je suis allé voir un film chez une
meuf mais c'est enfin je suis juste allé
voir un film un début que un début il me
reste un mois si jamais viennent me
reparler ok si jamais ell viennent pas
je m'en fiche
is ça il reste 32 jours j'aurais bien
voulu être avec les autres pour fêter la
fin d'année pour fêter le passage au
lycée ou même ne serait-ce que pour être
avec enfin pour être avec les potes quoi
ça aurait pu être cool
mais et je pense que je pense que si si
jamais j'étais resté au collège de ça
aurait été beaucoup plus simple aussi
niveau brevet ton oral fa comment j'ai
pas d'oral pas d'orale toute façon là le
brevet je vais pas dire que j'ai pas
révisé mais je vais pas dire que j'ai
révisé de fou non plus quoi non mais
quandme tu peux le voir ouais mais tu
vois toi tu étais en cours et tu as pu
écouter en cours alors que moi bah non
quoi mais en vrai en vrai je pense que
ça va le faire en vrai je pense que ma
matière où je vais le moins gérer ça va
quand même rester l'histoire géo mais
bon je vais essayer de me dépatouiller
puis en français pareil la rédaction ça
va aussi peut-être un peu un peu être
mon point faible mais je pense que
j'aurai mon brevet je pense que il y a
pas trop de doute
là-dessusis bah ouais bon allez je
passes le bonjour à tout le
monde good
bye
alors histoire et ce sera SVT physique
ça bien pass que théoriquement je crois
il man qu
50 POS pour avoir mon brevet donc je dis
ça
deè juste que je peux y
[Musique]
arriver
bonjour introduction TR arguments par
paragp en TR de CR rigole lui il a
raison il raison il raison il
raison
[Musique]
connaissanance ça va all
stress le brevet nous y voilà
[Musique]
les notes de l'année sont déjà arrêtées
mais il s'agit tout de même de ne pas le
prendre à la
[Musique]
légèreouv pas
vreépreuve pages et la page 9 rendre
avec la copie nous la donner
[Musique]
alors rwan ce qui me paraît quand même
très intéressant c'est qu'il est
autonome par rapport à son travail et il
est en très bonne maîtrise quasiment
partout c'est c'est c'est bien c'est
solide ran je le trouve très drôle parce
qu'il est il a il a tout le temps envie
de bien faire mais pas forcément il pas
forcément prêt à fournir les efforts
pour faire pour atteindre l'objectif qui
qu' veut quoi nonchance non non mais ça
vient et puis ça va venir l'année
prochaine enfin c'est clair que il a il
grandit beaucoup
quoi Mohamed il va mieux me semble-t-il
là au deème trimestre c'était quand même
un petit peu plus délicat il a eu un
petit passage à vide mais là le 3è
trimestre pour moi est très rassurant et
en ce qui concerne l'échange oral moi je
le trouve plus présent toi je ne sais
pas si tu trouve une différence oui ça
dépend un peu de ses humeurs mais mais
oui globalement il est quand même bien
dedans il a envie de bien faire bon il a
il a tenté sa chance et il a essayé de
réagir au bon moment ouais maiselle il
est autonome il s'est s'organisé il est
très sérieux mais ma aurait pu investir
un petit peu plus petit manque de
rigueur dans certaines matières parce
que effectivement il va plutôt partir
dans le dessin mais c'est vrai qu'il
faudra qu'il confirme quand même dans la
rédaction et le
raisonnement
je cont géré
ouais j'ai gér si tu
veux quand je dis que 2h c'est trop
l dem avant non mais ça fait 15 minutes
déjà là que j'ai terminé tu as mis
combien de temps au lieu de combien 1h15
au lieu de
2h on a essayé de nous nous mettre un
peu la pression pour qu'on travaille
quoi mais bon les épreuv était pas si
difficile que
ça très bien je pense que je l'ai déjà
donc le premier vrai examen de leur vie
se termine à peine oui mais il Tom là où
il y avait de la place hein
et déjà un grand
stress surtout pour
Mohamed il espère intégrer le très
réputé lycée châteaubillant juste à côté
une voix royale pour les
[Musique]
études pour l'année prochaine je bien
mais ce n'est pas son lycée de secteur
rien n'est sûr et ton affation merci
beaucoup son avenir écrit sur ce
papier ok c'eston merci beaucoup et
bonne bah bonnes
vacances je accepté la
château hein ouais ça un château
ouaisasy ouis écoute c'était trop
tard je suis cont oh là
là c'est comment c'est commentcept ch
voilà OK voilà on va mettre des
couleurs
chteau incroable je rentré wouh cont
ouais je suis
content bah au revoir merci beaucoup he
au revoir les garçons bonne continuation
ouais tu vas où à CH tu es content ouais
on y
va au revoir tu vas me menter ah
vraiment tu manqu
frère sattrape tu vas
où moi je vais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
làell la période du collège se termine
aujourd'hui au
[Musique]
revoir
Mo une nouvelle époque s'ouvre celle du
lycée elle reste à
[Musique]
écrire